pour nombre de participants le procès
des attentats du Bataclan a été le
dossier d'une vie vous étiez du côté des
parties civils avez-vous vous aussi le
sentiment que ce procès était historique
je me rends compte maintenant sur le
moment je suis dans mon procès je vis
mon procès à 100%, je suis tellement
concentrée sur sur ma tâche que je n'en
prends pas encore la mesure mais
maintenant qu'on en est sorti et que je
vois avec quelles difficultés aussi on
en sort même nous les professionnels je
me rends compte avec du recul
qu'effectivement on a vécu un procès
absolument incroyable on voit là une
planche de Charlie Hebdo lui dans un
hors-série à plus d'un titre ce procès
était hors norme de par son envergure ça
des mesures sa longueur le nombre des
victimes ça charge émotionnelle et bien
sûr symbolique son décorum aussi peut-on
dire également qu'il a été conforme aux
droits et est-ce que l'on pouvait en
attendre
alors j'ai réfléchi beaucoup mais pas
seulement au stade de l'audience le
terrorisme c'est vraiment une une
matière qui nous plonge tous dans notre
effroi dans notre émotion la plus la
plus profonde et effectivement le
respect de la norme du début à la fin
pose question depuis la récolte des
preuves on a parlé durant le procès
notamment de d'épreuve de guerre qui
doivent normalement répondre à des
conditions de récolte jusqu'à
l'exécution des peines est-ce que
l'exécution des peines appréhendait
tension le parcours des accusés se
fait-il de la même façon est-ce qu'en
termes d'application des peines et de
temps long est-ce que les choses se
passent de la même façon à l'audience
oui la question s'est posée alors je
suis avocate victime mais je vais vous
je vais quand même tâcher de vous
répondre avec la plus grande sincérité
parce que objectivement même quand on
défend des victimes on se rend compte
parfois qu'il y a quand même des pas de
côté on sait quand même rendu compte que
dans ce procès on était sorti de la
route habituelle et je pense que c'est
dû à une chose
euh c'est aux critères quantitatifs
c'est-à-dire les victimes étaient
tellement nombreuses les victimes sont
tellement nombreuses que le procès voilà
le procès s'étire sur la longueur mais
d'une longueur complètement inédite est
nécessairement l'organisation des débats
se fait d'une façon différente en fait
c'est tout simple si après une attaque
terroriste les victimes ce chiffre en
dizaines bon il y a un équilibre entre
le box et
nécessairement
2000 participent 3000 parties civils que
nous sommes actuellement dans Nice 130
avocats je crois à peu près constitué
pour les attentats du 13 novembre 2015
on était près de 300 nécessairement il y
a un déséquilibre qui ne peut pas jouer
en faveur de la défense des accusés
nécessairement Claire's vous vous êtes
illustré lors de ce procès comme celle
grâce à qui cela Abdeslam a parlé
le moment le plus attendu de ce procès
mais personne n'y croyait plus c'est à
vous et grâce à vous qu'il a notamment
expliqué avoir renoncé à se faire
exploser le soir des attentats comment
avez-vous trouvé le ton et les mots
justes pour briser son mur du silence
autrement dit est-ce que vous avez fait
psychologie première langue
déjà je voudrais
associer ma console Aurélie cerceau
c'est une conserve avec laquelle j'ai
travaillé tout ce procès
on a parlé toutes les deux avec sa
ladeslam même au cours des suspensions
d'audience
on n'a pas fait de magie c'est pas huit
ans d'audience je pense simplement lui a
parlé normalement on la rejoint sur un
terrain humain je pense qu'il l'a senti
avocate des parties civils oui mais vous
allez continuer oui mais je pense que si
vous voulez je pense que les les débats
judiciaires la vertu des débats
judiciaires pour moi c'est de créer une
sorte de no man's land une sorte de zone
entre le box et les bandes partie
civiles dans laquelle on va pouvoir
apprendre l'un de l'autre c'est à dire
moi je suis convaincue que l'on peut
apprendre d'eux et apporter beaucoup aux
victimes que l'on représente en allant
chercher en fouillant en tâchant de
comprendre pourquoi du comment en
essayant de saisir ce point de bascule
finalement qui va les amener à adhérer à
l'idéologie de l'État islamique mais je
suis persuadée également à l'inverse que
les accusés ont des choses à apprendre
des victimes et on l'a vu du reste à
l'audience je me souviens d'un moment de
d'audience très fort une mère vient une
mère qui a perdu sa fille vient là-bas
et par le 2 de tous ses accusés en
disant qu'elle aurait pu être leur mère
les tenir dans leurs bras donc elle crée
en plus un lien avec eux de de mer et il
y en a un qui a réagi Sofiane Ayari
ça a déclenché quelque chose chez lui
cela amené à accepter de se livrer sur
une partie de son parcours alors ça a
pas été très long il a pas non plus tout
raconté puis c'est il ne sait pas livré
sur un épisode qui aurait pu impliquer
les autres et c'est co-accusé mais
malgré tout moi je l'ai entendu parler
raconter son histoire en Syrie et des
procès terrorisme j'en ai fait quand
même un certain nombre avant j'avais
jamais entendu ça et pour moi c'est une
éduque quelque chose qui s'est passé
avec cette mère et ça l'abdeslam il
était prêt à cela moi je pense ce garçon
évidemment pour tout le monde il incarne
le mal absolu c'est le seul survivant
des attentats mais malgré tout au-delà
du caractère humain de l'acte c'est un
être humain et je je suis assez
convaincue que ce garçon a un moment
donné s'est trouvé sur une ligne de
crête à basculer du mauvais côté moi
j'avais besoin dans l'intérêt de mes
clients Aurélie cerceau avait besoin
dans l'intérêt de ses clients et du
reste il y a beaucoup de participes qui
n'étaient pas nos clients et qui nous en
remercient et qui avait besoin de savoir
de comprendre de l'entendre et on y
arrive pas parce que on a fait huit ans
d'études mais parce qu'on lui parle
normalement parce que l'on comprenne
vraiment pourquoi le président de la
cour d'assise a coupé court à cet
échange et donner la parole à un autre
av
immédiatement refermé est-ce que c'est
un regret moi je veux pas me faire
l'avocat de salade Eslam il a fait ce
qu'il a fait et puis il a été condamné
et savait qu'il serait condamné très
sévèrement moi ce que j'ai regretté
pendant ces semaines d'audience c'est
que on ne l'a pas laissé
dire tout ce qu'il avait à dire et je
pense qu'il s'est braqué à cause de cela
c'est à dire que pour moi il y a un
droit fondamental pour un accusé c'est
de dire ce qu'il veut c'est même de ne
rien dire si une s'il ne veut rien dire
c'est de ne pas répondre un accusé a le
droit de mentir on a à apprendre des
mensonges d'un accusé on a on a à
prendre de sa version de son histoire il
me semble aussi que la politique n'est
pas suffisamment entrée dans ce procès à
chaque fois que ça la Tesla faisait l'é
de la cause djihadiste on avait
tellement peur que ce procès lui donne
une tribune que on a stoppé net pour moi
c'est un c'est un regret qu'on les
stopper c'est-à-dire que moi j'ai eu le
sentiment à plusieurs endroits que dès
qu'il commençaient à parler en fait on
l'arrêtait parce que sa parole est
inaudible et qu'il fallait d'une
certaine façon
lisser
lycée la parole qui serait entendue dans
dans cette salle alors c'est mon
interprétation n'est pas
l'interprétation tous les confrères
attention
certains confrères de partie civils
considèrent que c'est un grand manitou
un grand pervers qui aurait choisi un
peu ces interlocuteurs je n'ai pas
ressenti la journaliste est romancière
silicaster qui n'a pas raté un seul jour
de dudience pour Charlie Hebdo et ce
livre n'a pas caché son irritation face
aux provocations répétées parfois
ouvertement odieuse de cela Abdeslam
elle a vu dans sa nonchalance son mépris
une forme d'obscénité qui lui fera dire
qu'il faut une patience d'ange un seul
contrôle hors du commun pour interroger
Abdeslam car il mettrait les nerfs à vif
à un bloc de briques seriez-vous un
bonze
pas du tout vécu comme ça non je l'ai
pas moi je me retrouve je me retrouve
pas là-dedans c'est compliqué de
répondre à cela parce que
[Musique]
cela Abdeslam
incarne tout ce qui oppose l'État
islamique au système démocratique et à
notre État de droit si l'on veut
apprendre de lui il faut accepter
l'échange
qui implique la confrontation des idées
c'est sa position à lui elle n'est pas
la nôtre c'est celle que l'on condamne
dans notre système judiciaire et c'est
aussi tout ce qui fait la vertu et la
force de notre système judiciaire c'est
de condamner les gens après un débat
mais si on lui donne pas la possibilité
d'exprimer sa position on ne peut même
pas après aller le chercher dans ces
contradictions moi je n'ai pas ressenti
de provocation de sa part alors
peut-être les premiers jours et encore
peut-on parler de provocation il sortait
de six années
d'isolement il faut bien imaginer ce
qu'est l'isolement total l'absence de
vie totale de vie sociale l'absence de
de sexualité l'absence de de liens
amical familial ne pas pouvoir étreindre
ses proches attention je ne fais pas
d'angélisme et je ne victimise pas
j'essaye simplement d'analyser pourquoi
ce garçon finalement arrive le premier
jour comme une bête
comme une bête en cage ben moi je crois
que c'est assez simple il sort de 6 ans
complètement coupé du monde il arrive
dans une salle d'audience où tout le
monde bondé avec une attente et puis une
accusation publique extrêmement forte il
faut du temps et bien il lui a fallu du
temps pour s'apprivoiser pour revenir
dans l'échange ça s'est fait je sais que
ça a choqué beaucoup de monde par le
rire qui a pu être le leur de dans le
box mais petit à petit il me semble
qu'il revient et j'ai l'impression qu'on
a pas forcément suit faire tout le temps
peut-être je suis complètement naïve et
n'aurait-il de toute façon pas accorder
sa parole mais je reste convaincu que si
l'on si l'on reste sur un terrain
d'humanité on y arrive voilà on peut y
arriver dans une certaine mesure
certains vous ont reproché votre
empathie votre bienveillance à l'égard
du principal accusé ce qui au fond
revenait finalement indirectement à vous
blâmer d'avoir instaurer un dialogue
avec lui un lien on a également reproché
vous lisez à l'accusé de ne dénir
répondre qu'à vous autrement dit de
choisir son interlocutrice et d'orienter
ses réponses de façon à se montrer plus
humain bref d'être le maître du jeu et
de tirer les ficelles vous l'avez vécu
comme ça moi je n'ai pas pas vécu comme
ça je
alors du côté des parties civils je
pense qu'on a pas tous nous les avocats
la même conception du rôle qu'on doit
jouer dans l'audience certains de mes
confrères c'est leur position considère
que l'on est avocat en partie civile
pour corroborer ce qu'on appelle
l'action publique c'est-à-dire pour
venir en soutien de l'accusation du
travail des avocats généraux dans
certains procès peut-être
à taille plus réduite quand il y a
vraiment un doute sur la culpabilité des
accusés quand on est en quand on peut
redouter la reconnaissance du préjudice
de nos clients peut-être dans les procès
terrorisme non l'accusation pour moi en
tout cas c'est ma conception de de mon
rôle n'est pas de faire de jouer les
procureurs bis pour moi je sors de mon
rôle d'avocat dans ces dans ces procès
là mon rôle est de
permettre à chaque victime que
j'accompagne de
trouver un intérêt dans ce procès
l'intérêt n'est pas toujours le même
parce qu'il n'attendent pas la même
chose certains veulent comprendre
certains sont en colère certains veulent
l'entendre certains veulent les voir
certains veulent leur parler donc moi
mon travail c'est d'accompagner cela
d'accompagner au cours des débats
d'expliquer la façon dont les débats
vont se passer et pour moi
l'essentiel c'est de c'est de rentrer en
communication avec eux de parler de
poser des questions
libres à eux de faire ce qu'ils veulent
libre à eux de faire ce qu'ils veulent
certains confrères ont considérer que
salabdeslam ne leur répondait pas parce
qu'il choisissait ses interlocuteurs et
ben on va dire que oui d'une certaine
façon les a choisi mais je n'y vois pas
une perversité je n'y vois pas une
caractéristique de manipulation je ne
vois pas cela en salade d'eslam je suis
pas psychiatre je suis pas psychologue
c'est ma sensibilité mon voisin aura une
autre sensibilité moi je ne crois pas je
pense que si il accepte de me répondre
s'il accepte de répondre à Aurélie
cerceau ou à quelques autres confrères
c'est parce qu'il sent chez
l'interlocuteur il est pas il est pas
idiot ce garçon pour moi il nous parle
parce qu'il comprend que ça va pouvoir
se faire mais en fait c'est aussi cela
que je regrette souvent dans dans cette
matière dans la matière du terrorisme
c'est que les actes sont tellement
monstrueux tellement effrayant je veux
dire la douleur est tellement convoquée
que on règle trop facilement les choses
de façon manichéenne trop tranchée c'est
le bien contre le mal d'ailleurs il y a
eu des plaidoiries le Bien contre le Mal
forcément si ça la Tesla m'a parle c'est
pour dire des choses mauvaises des
mensonges des choses atroces ils ne
pouvait rien apporter dans ce procès
rien n'était acceptable pour les parties
civils moi je ne pense pas je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup il était inaudible
oui pour beaucoup il était inédit mais
après on peut pas le reprocher aux
victimes évidemment vraiment parce que
c'est compliqué en fait il les a rendus
dingue ils les a rendu dingue dans le
procès un coup il parle un coup il parle
pas donc pour les victimes c'est atroce
et d'ailleurs ce jour où il arrive en
disant bah je vais pas parler alors que
c'était quand même le jour où on allait
aborder les les faits du 13 novembre
président périez il y a pas c'était pas
prévu donc même lui il est quand même
assez stupéfait de cette position et
puis moi je je me tourne vers la gauche
et je vois les victimes dans la salle
enfin on sentait qu'il y avait une chape
de plomb mais le silence c'est terrible
c'est un mur c'est un c'est un support
il fallait le faire parler il fallait
obtenir quelque chose et les semaines
qui ont précédé ce jour-là on s'est
voilà moi je le salue tous les jours
quand j'arrive à l'audience je salue les
autres on avait déjà échangé au cours de
certains entretiens il a compris que
j'allais pas le piéger j'ai les papiers
voilà la peine prononcée contre cela
Abdeslam la peine de perpétuité
incompressible
en fonction la plus lourde dans notre
droit introduite en 94 en 1994 vous
semble-t-elle à la fois juste et
justifier alors ça c'est pas l'avocat de
partie civile qui répond c'est l'avocat
de tout court parce qu'avant d'être
avocate victime on est avocat à tout
court et je suis par ailleurs dans
d'autres circonstances avocate en
défense donc je suis viscéralement
attaché aux droits humains pour moi
c'est justement certains de vos
confrères qui ont vu la victoire du
terrorisme dans ce Birdy c'est pour moi
cette peine ne devrait pas exister dans
le système judiciaire
elle est symbolique elle évite en
symbolique c'est un message
adressé au peuple c'est une restitution
une restitution symbolique pour la
nation pour le peuple finalement tous
les tous les observateurs extérieurs
considéraient que c'est ça qui incarne
mal absolu
devait être condamné au pire alors il a
été déguisé c'est une peine de mort
déguisée voilà il me semble que dans
notre système
judiciaire et carcéral on avait déjà
tout ce qu'il fallait pour le garder en
prison toute sa vie si c'est nécessaire
pour moi l'incompressibilité c'est un
surplus d'inhumanité qui pour moi ne
fait pas honneur à notre système
judiciaire parce que ça doit être
l'honneur du système judiciaire de
répondre au terrorisme moi je suis très
fière de notre justice justement celle
qui permet les débats celles qui permet
l'échange contradictoires c'est
exactement comment ce que l'on combat
finalement quand on combat l'État
islamique et les valeurs de l'État
islamique donc on oppose à l'état
islamique une justice fantastique dont
on se glorifie parce qu'on se glorifie
de ces procès et heureusement que ces
process se tiennent et je pensais
évidemment toutes les victimes que j'ai
accompagné mais répondre à une ligne
humanité par un surplus d'inhumanité ne
m'apparaissait pas nécessaire salade
d'eslam a participé à des actes
monstrueux il le sait il ne s'en est pas
caché il l'a même revendiqué il savait
qu'il allait écoper d'une peine
extrêmement grave il aurait pu être
condamné à perpétuité avec 30 ans de
peine de sûreté c'était pas la peine
d'en rajouter c'est à dire que oui
théoriquement il lui reste un espoir
dans 30 ans il pourra saisir un tribunal
d'application des peines pour essayer
d'obtenir justement la fixation d'une
période de sûreté c'est un espoir qui
est digne d'une feuille de papier voilà
alors ce verdict n'est-ce pas aussi une
façon de répondre indirectement à la
question que beaucoup se posent un
islamiste radicalisé peut-il changer car
ce verdict consiste tout simplement à
dire qu'il n'y a pas de retour possible
pour certaines personnes
c'est ce que nous dit ce verdict parce
que la peine est fixée en fonction des
possibilités de réadaptation donc quand
on prononce une peine de perpétuité
incompressible c'est que l'on considère
à l'issue des 10 mois d'audience qui
était foutu et qui ne présentait aucun
élément permettant de penser qu'un jour
il pourrait évoluer qu'on n'est pas
envie d'y penser que le peuple n'est pas
envie d'y penser ça je le comprends
c'est totalement humain mais que des
magistrats qui ont fait ce métier toute
leur vie
prennent cette décision ce jour-là moi
je n'y adhère pas et pourtant personne
ne pourra remettre en question tout
l'attachement et même l'amitié que je
porte à certaines victimes que
j'accompagne on a pleuré ensemble
pendant des années moi j'ai pleuré avec
eux
je n'ai jamais autant serré mes clients
dans les bras donc évidemment que quand
je dis ça je ne vais pas à l'encontre de
victimes je pense que c'est même
l'inverse parce que fondamentalement les
victimes veulent le retour à la sécurité
le retour à la sécurité antérieure et
pour ça il ne faut pas perdre nos
valeurs clash vite vous ne vous
destiniez pas être avocate vous avez
commencé par passer le prestigieux
concours de l'École Boulle avant de
céder à la pression familiale et de
passer le barreau qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé
j'ai bien ce que le métier d'avocat
n'est pas venu non plus après une
déception parce que je n'ai pas pu
embrasser une carrière artistique j'y ai
pensé même très très petite moi j'étais
fan d'une série qui m'a pas glamour et
je pense un peu de gens qui sont s'en
souviennent je regardais périméson
périméson c'est c'est celui justement
qui vient casser les certitudes moi ça
je suis venu au métier d'avocat par
périméson
non j'avais de toute façon cette
aspiration et puis j'étais j'ai toujours
été fascinée par le phénomène criminel
et par le besoin de comprendre pourquoi
et ce qui amène un être humain à passer
à la mais j'avais par ailleurs des
aspirations artistiques très fortes
alors je n'ai pas tension j'ai pas passé
le concours de l'École Boulle j'ai passé
en cachette le le petit examen pour
rentrer à l'école et j'ai été très
faible je mon père a dit non c'est un
nom sans appel et à l'époque j'étais pas
suffisamment costaud et solide pour dire
ben je ferai ce que je veux bon j'ai
fait des études de droit et puis ce qui
va se passer c'est passé j'ai mis de
côté la profession d'avocat et je suis
allée travailler la mosaïque à la mort
de votre main effectivement vous quittez
la robe pour vivre 1000 vies vous allez
exercer un nombre de métiers
impressionnant chef cuisinier fondeur
d'or du Marais mosaïste vous avez
travaillé chez une mosaïste italienne
vous avez été un temps hôtesse de l'air
et vous avez même pensé vous lancer en
politique
oui oui
de toute façon voilà si on suit beaucoup
trop les prescriptions parentales voilà
ce qui se passe donc bah moi je vais
essayer de
nécessairement bon je n'en veux pas non
plus
à mon père pour ça parce que j'exerce
aujourd'hui un métier vraiment que
j'adore je suis passionnée par mon
métier j'adore mon métier d'avocat je et
je n'ai aucune difficulté à passer de la
défense d'une victime à la défense
pénale d'un accusé je suis passionnée
par par mon métier alors vous dites
effectivement aujourd'hui quelque chose
de plaider pour des valeurs que vous
partagez vous défendez aussi bien terre
des femmes engagé contre les violences
sexistes que Greenpeace qui lutte pour
la survie de la planète autant dire que
des causes nobles c'est un luxe inouï
mais je n'ai que de la chance je suis
une avocate chanceuse je pense que c'est
pas donné à tout le monde mais tous les
matins je me lève pour faire ce que
j'aime mais est-ce que vous pourriez
défendre un violent d'enfant ou un
terroriste islamiste un terroriste
islamiste oui j'aurais pu maintenant
c'est plus compliqué parce que
j'interviens depuis un certain nombre
d'années maintenant pour des victimes
d'attentat pour l'Association française
des victimes du terrorisme donc ça
risquerait de me placer dans ce qu'on
appelle un conflit d'intérêt donc je
serai certainement en matière terroriste
amenée à dire non mais non pas pour des
questions de principes personnelles
j'aurais pu défendre des terroristes
islamistes mais je ne ferai pas pour des
raisons déontologiques le Graal serait
pour vous aujourd'hui de rejoindre la
Cour pénale internationale l'instance
chargé de juger les génocides crimes de
guerre et crimes contre l'humanité que
du léger
que du léger mais parce que alors je
vais vous dire sincèrement les choses
après le V13 on est allé loin et j'ai
pas forcément envie de repartir en
arrière sur
des procès qui m'intéresseraient moins
j'ai maintenant bon puis j'ai 50 ans
j'ai des attentes intellectuelles j'ai
envie de continuer à passer ses journées
palpitantes j'aime aussi le lien qu'il y
a entre mon métier et l'actualité de mon
pays avec la CPI je voudrais qu'il y ait
un lien entre mon métier et l'actualité
du monde dans lequel je vis et dans ma
candidature il y avait des cases à
cocher préfériez vous défendre des
accusés ou des victimes moi j'ai coché
la case pas de préférence voilà moi je
continuerai à défendre des des personnes
accusées de merde d'assassinat de je
vais bientôt un dossier de viol pour moi
il n'y a pas de il y a pas de camp à
choisir
je pense même que ça peut être la force
d'un avocat de pouvoir plaider en partie
civile et côté accusé parce que parce
qu'on connaît les deux les deux parties
et puis pour moi tout ce qui est
richesse oui oui puis c'est moi je
finalement j'ai pas fait de politique
pour ça parce que pour moi ça n'a pas de
sens d'être tanqué dans un camp
en revanche faire un lien entre nos
valeurs
morales nos convictions d'avocats notre
passion de défendre et puis avoir la
chance qui est la mienne de pouvoir
plaider dans des dossiers qui font le
lien avec le monde dans lequel je vis
mais c'est un c'est un luxe inouï
comment êtes-vous sorti de cette
cathédrale de la douleur pour reprendre
l'expression de Sylvie Casta le terme de
ces 10 mois de procès V13 alors après le
procès est très alors cathédrale de
douleur je c'est compliqué pour les
professionnels mais attention enfin on
est
on la met pas au même niveau que celle
des victimes bien évidemment mais oui
c'est quelque chose qui nous a tellement
occupé pris au tripes et puis les procès
d'assis c'est tellement addictif on les
vit intensément donc effectivement il y
a eu un petit down derrière c'est pas
simple et c'est très rassurant quand on
vient de congé au mois de septembre
parce que tous les professionnels qu'on
croise personne ne va bien
avocat magistrat journaliste on est tous
un peu en post-troma et ça nous plonge
dans des états complètement inédits
parce que bon les assis ça fait toujours
ça c'est vrai quand on sort des assises
il faut se remettre dans le monde mais
là ça a été dix mois donc bah on s'y
remet en prenant la vie quotidienne et
puis on passe à d'autres procès et en
même temps il faut pas non plus
laisser tomber les victimes parce que
pour les victimes il y a le temps long
le procès ne règle pas tout donc il faut
continuer à accompagner donc bah on fait
comme d'habitude on essaie d'être sur
tous les fronts merci merci à vous merci
infiniment